[Music]
generation shifts are an opportunity to
push beyond the boundaries of gaming as
we know it today and this time is no
different our studios are taking their
crazy ambitious ideas and making them
real criterion is known for how their
games feel from superior physics to
nuanced details of gameplay this team
hand curates the moment-to-moment
experience and with the new consoles
this year there will be a seamless
immersion which will get you into the
race in a matter of seconds
[Music]
Bioware imagines and creates worlds
where you've become the hero of your own
story and we're using this next
generation of technology to make those
fantasy worlds your reality for every
console generation dice sets the bar for
excellence in audio and visual
presentation we are creating epic
battles at a scale and fidelity unlike
anything you've experienced before
at motive we are working on a highly
ambitious and innovative new game that
puts the power and creativity in your
hands and it's an experience that would
have been impossible without next-gen
technology
[Music]
this is just the beginning of the things
we are working on and there are so much
more to come the future of EA Studios is
not just about new technology it's about
you your voices your ideas we want to be
where you come to play we want to make
games for everyone so please keep giving
us your feedback and let's build the
future together on behalf of all of our
studios thank you for joining us today